Okay. I'm here to talk about agent card.
Agent card, as you can tell,
is a debit card for AI agents.
You may be wondering why
would I wanna do that.
Claude
Okay. And how many of you have tried
to buy something with OpenClaw?
Okay. Um,
so when you try to buy
things with your agent, uh,
there are many things. There
are many issues with that.
And number one is that it's not safe to
share your credit card with your agent.
What what we basically created,
it's a very simple interface that you can
use and your agent can use to issue one
time cards that are safe and
very and very easy to use, um,
that you can start using right now,
actually, if you go into our website,
agentcard.sh. What I'm gonna
show you next is how, uh,
you can create a card. And we
will also try to buy something,
which may or may not work.
Um, okay.
Claude and
I've already of course, like,
I have my agent card account
here and my MCP server connected.
So I'm just gonna do create a card.
And what it's going to
do is talk to our MCP
server, and it's asking me
what the limit should be.
So I'm gonna say I actually I'm gonna
choose something else, like, maybe $1.
And couple seconds later,
um, it's gonna ask for my approval.
You may be wondering why is it asking
for your approval if you just said, like,
create the card. And that's because this,
uh, flow, it it's has been started by me,
but could have been started
by your agent directly.
So before car creation, you as a
human need to up approve car creation.
So I'm gonna say yes. Um,
and if everything works fine,
we should see the card any second now.
Okay. That's it. Now I'm gonna say, okay.
Show me the card.
And this is not being livestreamed,
so people online are not gonna be able to
steal the card, but you can if you want.
It's again, it's gonna
ask for my approval.
I'm gonna say yes. And now it's
gonna show us the the real card.
Great. There it is. Okay.
So this is a one time card,
which means that after first use,
it's gonna get destroyed, which is
means that it's very safe to use.
Claude and it's fine. Uh,
it's fine if the LM sees it.
There's, uh, nothing to worry about there.
I don't know if I have enough time to
buy something, but we're gonna try.
Okay.
So I'm gonna try to pay for this OpenAI
subscription. So I'm gonna say,
open this in a in a browser and
pay for it.
So, basically, the agent
card MCP has a tool that, uh,
can recognize URLs and is able to
complete, uh, a transaction like this.
It's able to buy things for you.
So it's opening the browser,
and it should now open the URL.
And what it's going to do,
it's detect on the screen
how much it needs to pay for,
and it's gonna create a
onetime card for that amount.
So in this case, it's
gonna be a card for $8.
It's asking again for my authorization.
I'm gonna say yes.
And if I can do it in eight
seconds, it would be amazing.
Let's see if that works.
Yes. You have my approval.
And it's now here on the browser.
We can see the cursor. And any second now,
it should be able to
complete this checkout.
It's very hard to do a live
demo of something in Claude.
Okay. Yeah. There it is. Okay.
Okay. So that's agent card for you all.
You can go ahead and create
an account on agent card.
Try to buy things with your agents.
It's all of us on this audience, the ones
who are building the tools for the future,
so go ahead and do crazy
things with your agents.
Thank you very much.